en el vídeo pasado hablamos acerca de la
corriente y la corriente es el
movimiento de la carga la cantidad de
carga que se mueve por segundo
observamos un cable de cobre donde los
electrones están moviendo la carga pero
también observamos una solución de sal
donde los iones cloro y sodio son los
que están moviendo la carga a través de
esta barrera imaginaria en la cual
estamos observando el movimiento de
carga bueno pero ahora vamos a hablar
acerca de la corriente positiva pero
para eso necesitamos más espacio y bueno
hemos llegado a un punto que siempre
provoca mucha confusión pero vamos a
tratar de explicarlo lo mejor posible
tenemos una convención de signos para la
corriente la corriente fluye en sentido
positivo cuando fluye en el sentido en
el que fluyen los iones positivos así es
que como aquí tenemos al sodio que es un
ión positivo que está fluyendo en esta
dirección cuando la corriente fluye en
sentido positivo
en esta misma dirección aunque tenemos
aquí a los iones negativos al cloro que
está fluyendo en esta dirección así es
que este es el sentido en el que fluye
la corriente cuando fluye en el sentido
positivo y sucede exactamente lo mismo
en un cable de cobre si tenemos aquí el
cable de cobre por aquí adentro vamos a
tener un montón de electrones fluyendo y
sabemos que están fluyendo en esta
dirección por lo que q - está fluyendo
en esta dirección por lo que cuando
dibuja la flecha que refleja la
dirección de la corriente la dibujo en
este sentido la corriente positiva está
fluyendo en esta dirección y entonces si
por ejemplo aquí yo tuviera 10
electrones moviéndose en esta dirección
yo diría que tengo más 10 cargas
moviéndose en esta dirección y muchas
veces nos preguntamos bueno si siempre
son los electrones los que están
cargando la corriente por
hacemos esto de poner la flecha en
sentido contrario y la razón se remonta
en la historia hasta ben franklin cuando
decidió que la carga del electrón tiene
signo menos lo hizo indirectamente en
ese entonces todavía no se había
descubierto el electrón así es que ben
franklin en 1747 fue quien asignó más y
menos a los dos tipos de cargas que
existían y en los tiempos en los que lo
hizo nadie sabía que existían los
electrones el electrón fue descubierto
por jay jay y samson hasta 1897
jey jey jey y sampson descubrió el
electrón en 1897 y bueno si nos fijamos
en la diferencia entre estos dos años
lo creas o no son 150 años de diferencia
por 150 años hicimos investigación
acerca de la electricidad sin conocer a
los electrones y asignándole a la
corriente una dirección contraria a la
que realmente llevan los electrones
cuando transportan la carga en un metal
pero está muy bien todo funciona muy
bien y bueno también muchos de mis
estudiantes me preguntan oye pero por
qué no lo hemos regresado para que
tengan la misma dirección porque no
hacemos que la corriente tenga esta
dirección lo que hay porque no
simplemente definimos a la corriente en
la misma dirección que los electrones
porque es cierto llevábamos 150 años
estudiando a la corriente de esta forma
pero ahora llevamos más de 120 años
desde el descubrimiento de los
electrones y nos las hemos arreglado
bastante bien para superar todos los
problemas que pueda generar esto así es
que simplemente no hemos decidido
hacerlo porque además una de las razones
más importantes por las que no hemos
cambiado
el sentido de la corriente es porque
sería un desastre sería muy complicado y
desordenado imagina por un momento que
en tu ciudad
de repente decidimos que vamos a cambiar
la dirección en la que fluyen los coches
ok ahorita en la mayoría de las ciudades
los coches circulan del lado derecho de
la calle imagina el caos que se armaría
si de repente decidimos que ahora los
coches fluyen del lado izquierdo de la
calle imagina nada más el caos que se
provocaría antes del cambio todo el
mundo puede llegar a dónde quiere llegar
sin ningún problema y después del cambio
todo el mundo va a poder seguir llegando
a dónde quiere ir sin ningún problema
pero el cambio en sí nos costaría
muchísimo trabajo y bueno sucede
exactamente lo mismo con la electricidad
todo funciona perfectamente bien cuando
pensamos que la corriente fluye en el
sentido de la carga positiva como lo
hicimos aquí con los iones de sodio
positivos que fluyen en esta dirección y
por lo tanto la corriente fluye en esta
dirección
el cual por cierto así es como se
conduce la electricidad en tu cuerpo no
es nada extraño tener cargas positivas
fluyendo por todos lados pero bueno esta
es la definición de corriente colocamos
una barrera imaginaria y nos ponemos a
observar cuántas cargas fluyen a través
de esa barrera en cierto tiempo en la
dirección en la que está influyendo y
las sumas y obtienes cuántas cargas
fluyeron a través de esa barrera por
segundo y esa es la corriente